we are told all the time that the reason
for this high tax level is that we're
going to get good public services but
the problem is that we don't have good
public services what works best in a way
is the private markets hi I'm Michael
Moynihan with Reason TV and today we are
talking with Stevenson the head of the
Progress Party Norway is second largest
party correct for opposition party so
tell us that we get often in America
this discussion about how Norway is one
of the greatest places to live and how
we should kind of formulates American
policy something like Norwegian policy
on health care and taxes etc you I
suspect would disagree with that I find
it actually very strange that you would
like to adopt to a system that is not
working let me talk to about a
healthcare for instance in Noah we have
a state monopoly health care which means
basically that's when you are in need of
an operation and you don't get it you
have to wait and sometimes you have to
wait even for a year before it's it
suits the government's to give you one
and you have no other alternative is
private your insurance allowed it is
allowed but it's extremely expensive and
you have to remember we have a taxpayer
financed healthcare system which is not
so bad
the problem is that we do have a
monopoly system which means that we will
not allow any private hospitals to take
part in the system and when you leave
them out you don't get the necessary
competition or the the right to choose
as a patient and that actually brings
the system down instead of putting the
patients in the center of the hole
losses
I think most people would say that this
is amazing that somebody in Norway would
criticize this this perfect system and
we often hear of it as a perfect system
but to be clear you're the second
biggest party in Norway you poll around
mid-20s 25 percent 24 percent or
something so this kind of view is
resonating I mean what is what is making
the progress party so popular in Norway
I mean is is it healthcare is it people
that are fed up with taxes and you know
paying when I was in Oslo paying $12 for
a beer and things like that I mean what
is what is the sort of you know
motivation for people to vote for the
Progress Party I think the basic idea is
freedom I think that the average
Norwegian is sick and tired of
interference in their daily life
regulations bureaucracy high taxes are
and then we are told all the time that
the reason for this high tax level is
that we're going to get good public
services but the problem is that we
don't have good public services what
works best in a way is the private
market all others are state controlled
monopolies and they don't work give us
an idea of the sort of tax burden in
Norway we know they're very high taxes
but just how high are they I mean the
tourist experiences that's when buying a
pack of cigarettes which is how much all
tax is included for for an average
Norwegian direct and indirect taxes I
think it adds up to about seventy
seventy five percent of your income
which is substantial that's rather low
ah so good extremely expensive let's
take a gallon of gas I hear you complain
over here about the prices on gas it
become very expensive yeah well if you
want to know the Norwegian price for a
gallon of gas and we have to remember we
are the second biggest oil and gas
producer in the world I think the price
would be around $7 50 for a gala and you
can play yes yeah
and alcohol for instance this is an
enormous is monopoly in it as a matter
of fact that you shop is called the wine
monopoly it is what what is I mean
was an idea with taxes are on the sort
of sin taxes in Norway they're
ridiculously high which means that I
actually can't remember the prices right
now but it's expensive you want to buy a
bottle of wine just a regular bottle of
wine it would be like a hundred
Norwegian krone owners which is fifteen
dollars I guess something like that in
about half of that is tax yeah yes
something like that
so what is the free for your party
platform when you're arguing in local
elections and even in national elections
what is what and you're promising to
reduce taxes and reduce the size of
government in Norway correct yeah that's
important after remember Norway's a very
small country we have a population of
five million people approximately but we
have a size of governments or the
government bureaucracy that would make
us have a population about 15 million
people that's crazy so Rick it's
ridiculous and extremely expensive for
the taxpayers to do finance we don't
need that we could actually make it work
in a simple way by reducing the
bureaucracy reducing tax and stop
interfering in people's lives we can
actually make decisions by ourselves
Seve thank you for visiting with us a
recent TV for reason TV I'm Michael
Moynihan
you